this is what I'm talking about here the
people waiting to get into hall h h4 hot
miserable weather h4 hellishly long
waits h4 hey I think I see george RR
martin i oh it's just a homeless guy
never mind anyway I'm going to talk to
some of these people the most dedicated
of the dedicated ask them why they're
here what they're hoping to see how long
they've been waiting i'm here with
Captain America which version of Captain
America are you the stealth suit from
the winter soldier excellent great
costume that's a nice sturdy shield too
I got a shield but it was just like a
trash can lid it bent up the first time
I threw it can you tell me is that
vibranium is that adamantium or is it a
vibranium adamantium alloy I would say
it's a both both of them it's the alloy
that is correct that is the proper
version of Captain America's shield what
are they doing with the movie pure
vibranium you know if he tried to
ricochet that around a pure vibranium
shield it would absorb that force and
drop like a dead tennis ball isn't that
right that's right but I'm pretty sure
they don't use the word adamantium
because it's sewn by fox i'm here with
two cosplayers the outfits look vaguely
familiar i can't quite put my finger on
it can you tell me who you're supposed
to be I am Marge Simpson and so am i
great so body make it what what color
would be best for me if I was going to
slather makeup over every inch of my
body that's a great question sponge cake
yellow bus bonds k yellow sponge cake
yellow I like it your costumes I love
the attention to detail they're almost
perfect the only thing lacking is that
classic Matt graining underbite can you
do that wrong can you tell me who you
are cosplaying as
Peter Pan and Tinkerbell police costumes
are great they're very accurate but I'm
disappointed you didn't go the extra
mile and miniaturize yourself to be
about this tall the scale is all wrong
it's that attention to detail that
really sets apart you know that the
great cause players and speaking of
miniaturization that reminds me Marvel
Studios just revealed the new ant-man
poster and I'm livid I still can't get
over the fact that out of the thousands
of characters they had to choose from
they decided to build a movie around
this miniaturized mediocrity look
there's ant-man riding an ant you better
hope the bad guy doesn't have a giant
can of raid so the cast of age of Ultron
were just here we were kept a safe
distance away from them I don't know if
they thought some sort of rabid fan boys
we're going to hug and smooch and hug
and smooch some more on them it's like a
Marvel Last Supper which one of you will
betray me tonight probably Hawkeye
anyway I'm on record saying that there
have been far too many Marvel superhero
movies in the last decade roll the clip
in the last decade alone there have been
40 of them it's too much it's also
increasingly infuriating that the
separate franchise is fantastic for
spider-man and the Avengers cannot
overlap something has to be done about
that I am surrounded by things that make
me furious like the geeks who wait in
line overnight to see a movie trailer
that will be available freely online a
week from now next year stay home people
and then I won't have to wait in line is
long
you